Please welcome James Beard,
Award-winning Kwame Onwuachi.
(crowd cheering)
I'm so happy to be back.
I mean, I'm so happy that you're back on the show
and I'm not gonna hesitate to brag.
You are number one on Amazon for your cookbook right now
and it hasn't even come out.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you
Number one, with a bullet!
We did it. We're doing it.
I mean, how good does that feel?
It feels so good for a multitude of reasons, right?
Like I'm able to really share my culture.
And I think so many people have different versions
of what American food was for them growing up.
Yeah.
For me, it was curried chicken, oxtails,
jolof rice, egusi soup.
So this book is my love letter back to America.
It's full of all the recipes that I've cooked
and all the classics.
So we're gonna cook one today.
I cannot wait, teach me everything.
All right.
By the way, loving the new season of "Top Chef."
It's good.
It's so good.
It's been fun. It's been a lot of fun.
And it's in Houston, which is a great city.
I know I'm loving this season so much.
Yeah. All right.
So what we're gonna do first is we're gonna make
our green seasoning.
So green seasoning is a Caribbean marinade.
It goes with vegetables,
it goes with meats.
And we're just gonna add this to the blender.
So we have green onions, all of our, our aromatics in there.
We have some-
Celery, thyme.
Onion.
We have ginger garlic paste.
Ginger garlic paste.
And then we have some...
You like your food spicy, I remember.
I do. I do.
I remember.
It's 'cause I've dulled this pallet over the years.
The years.
So then we have some pepper sauce.
So just put that on top and hit that button.
And I want the crowd to go, "Go, go go."
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Yeah.
(blender whirring)
That's it, that's it.
That enough?
That's enough.
I hate when it like frappes too much
and it starts get foamy, ugh.
And it's so mushy, yeah.
So put some little bit of oil in there.
The whole thing, or just a-
Just a little bit. There you go.
You're gonna add your onions to that.
Oh yeah.
Sounds good, right.
It does, I love a sizzle.
We're gonna add our green seasoning
and you could smell this already.
Yeah, you wanna get all of that?
Oh yeah, you do. This is why I love a silicone spoon.
Exactly. So then we have two spice blends.
So we have a toasted curry powder
and then we have a house spice
which is my mom's all purpose seasoning.
It's something that she always kept in arms reach
when she was making any dish.
So there's like coriander, there's fenugreek,
there's turmeric, there's cumin-
I love fenugreek.
And then in the house spice is like
black pepper, cayenne, garlic powder, onion powder.
So there's so much-
There's cumin.
Cumin.
I love it, I smell the cumin.
There's so much flavor developing-
I don't know about anybody else
but cumin to me smells like a sexy boyfriend t-shirt.
(crowd laughs)
So you got that.
You're gonna add your chickpeas to that.
Okay.
And this is a quick dish but it has a lot of flavor
that's built up and that's what a lot of the recipes
are indicative of
that are in this book.
So mix that up.
The smell is just insane.
It is so vibrant.
(crowd cheering)
So on my side, I kind of got the same thing going on here.
I've had chicken, that's been marinating for 24 hours
in that green seasoning.
I've seared it, put some of the seasoning to the side.
Okay.
And I'm gonna add it back to the pan.
So I'm gonna mirror what you're doing.
Ah, the scent of this it's like curry-
It's crazy-
And a lemon tree growing out of it
and onion and garlic and the pepper.
So you got that simmering, I've got mine simmering.
And then you just put a lid on it.
Next to you we have some-
Put a lid on it.
That's it.
(crowd laughs)
And next to you, you got the curry already ready to go.
Look at how absolutely stunning this is.
Could I put it on the rice?
Yeah, put it right on there.
I'm gonna put chicken on mine.
It's so versatile.
It just falls off the bone.
Kwame, could you...
(crowd cheering)
Just put some chopped cilantro on there.
I am so excited.
Let me cheers real quick?
Oh, (indistinct).
Cheers my love.
Thanks, cheers.
(crowd cheering)
I'm so happy to be with you.
And I'm (indistinct).
(crowd cheering)
Oh man.
(hums) I'm like getting that heat up in the nose.
(Drew sniffs)
mm hmm.
Really, really hearty.
Very comforting, the chickpeas are melt in your mouth.
Yeah.
It's so beautiful.
Thank you. Thank you.
Kwame, no wonder you're number one with a bullet
on Amazon before your book even came out.
Thank you so much.
How amazing is that?
Thank you.
(crowd cheering)
I was so excited when I saw it.
'Cause I follow you on Instagram and I saw it.
I mean, and I just have to say
as a cookbook club person and a collector of cookbooks,
I love the cover of your book.
I think it's really soulful and beautiful.
It feels personal, it's graphic.
I love the font you chose
and it just makes me wanna dive in.
Thank you, thank you.
You know, it's really a collection of stories
bigging up to the people that came before me,
the people that really made these recipes who they are.
There's anecdotes before each recipe
that tells you the history of jerk,
that tells you the path that curry took to the Caribbean.
So you get to really know the why behind
why these dishes have stood the test of time for so long.
Well, you're such an honoring person.
It really doesn't surprise me.
So get your copy now of
"My America Recipes From A Young Black Chef"
available on May 17th
already number one.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪